[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to our March
2025 xiaomi product launch today xiaomi
is going to reach the next Pinnacle in
Innovative
technology hello everyone I'm will our
strud car home Shi officially enter the
E market last March in just 11 months
180,000
vehicles our show me su7 arra becoming
the F for car on the fmer new Bine race
track I'm so excited to tell our Global
users that xiaomi will be releasing EV
for the sale in global markets with the
next few years we also be officially
launch large home app places in the
global markets later this year
let's talk a little bit about xiaomi
hyper os2 hypercore is the underlying
technology of os2 homescreen plus 2.0
lets you get access to your smartphone
screen and functionality straight from
your xiaomi pad it's never been more
convenient or more fun xiaomi
hyperconnect now works with select Apple
devices and we can't wait for all of you
to enjoy the smooth connected experience
xiaomi hyper aai through text speech
search and image generation helping make
your productivity more powerful and more
personal actually just earlier this year
unbox therapy had a chance to get
Hands-On he loved how we've worked with
Google to create a complete operating
system today we're bringing our most
powerful AI assistant to the xiaomi 15
series with Google Gemini Gemini will be
able to connect across xiaomi apps
including xiaomi clock notes and
calendar
for more details on the release schedule
of xiaomi hyper aai and xiaomi Hyper os2
just pop over to me.com for more details
starting with xiaomi 15 xiaomi 15 will
offer an absolute Flagship experience
matching the best devices in the world
beautifully refined in its design it's
also built to last we're introducing the
fundamental experience of xiaomi
Guardian structure Shi 15's colors are
subtle yet bold this year we've gone
above and Beyond introducing liquid
silver and just how it looks how it was
built is as impressive next let's talk
display on a 6.36 in display the top and
the side bezels are all 1.38 mm the
bottom bezel is also 1.38 mm we are also
bringing the ultrasonic fingerprint
experience to xiaomi 15 series on xiaomi
15 the sumu lens has an upgraded Al anti
reflective coding and any of the shots
you take will look amazing across the
three cameras on xiaomi 15 to capturing
a shot only takes 0.6 seconds xiaomi
15's Leica triple fast lens offers a
leading smartphone photography
experience xiaomi 15 series comes with
the industry-leading Snapdragon 8 Elite
chipset it's our first mobile platform
to integrate our new second generation
Qualcomm Orion CPU with our industry
leading Qualcomm adreno GPU you will see
a 40% boost in performance coupled with
a 40% reduction in power
consumption now with great performance
comes the need for powerful cooling
xiaomi 15 integrates a new generation
xiaomi ice Loop cooling system and with
xiaomi hypercore mixed into the pack
becomes one of the most powerful
smartphones shiai 15 ends up with a
massive 5,240
milliamp hour
battery let's get right into the best of
the best today
Ultra let's start with design xiaomi 15
ultra's color and design are inspired by
traditional professional camera designs
silver Chrome white and black now xiaomi
Guardian structure 2.0 from the
structure to the display to the back and
of course a requirement for flagships
ip68 moving on to display all around
liquid display is a subtle but highly
tuned iteration of display Form and
Function Ultra immersive display
experience it has incredible resolution
brightness and smoothness this is an
ultra visual experience that is a
non-negotiable when you're looking to
create a pinnacle level device now when
it comes to Performance xiaomi 15 Ultra
always offers the best available so
we're dedicated to Pinnacle performance
in our Ultra devices insane performance
exceptional cooling Ultra long battery
and
hypercharge I'm very proud personally on
the xiaomi Leica Corporation now we are
in the fourth year what we have we
achieved so far 21 co-engineered
products Market expansion across five
regions and over 100 countries xiaomi
also has taken over with masterclass we
contribute with photographers to inspire
xiaomi imagery award a give young
photographers a platform a chance to
show what they can
the biggest porn of the day camera the
xiaomi Leica partnership is a
Cornerstone in providing users with the
very best Mobile Imaging experience when
we talk about mobile Optics we mean
three different factors leading design a
pinnacle main camera and the best
telephoto possible the Leica ultra low
reflection Optical glass nearly a
two-fold increase in drop resistance and
reduces light reflection we're ensuring
professional grade light transmission
we've used materials that include an
eight-piece lens that features
specialized lens Coatings that enhance
image quality a 13 Channel spectral
sensor helps you professionally balance
the color temperature and AWB accuracy
even more important than that is the
versatility and the quality of the
primary sensor we've paired a 1-in
sensor with an ultra llarge aperture
sumu lens with the optical upgrades of
the xiaomi 15 Ultra and the xiaomi aisp
we are able to bring true Optical flavor
to night photography next up this is
xiaomi most powerful and advanced
telephoto camera ever the 15 Ultras
telephoto camera is an industry-leading
200 megapixel sensor brings a whole new
level of telephoto Hardware to Global
markets and we call this experience
Ultra telephotography covering a range
of portrait to night to fast capture
there's a certain Trinity of lenses we
have the 14 mm Leica ultrawide with a
large f2.2 aperture a 23mm main camera
that captures up to 2x 46 mm focal
length and two amazing teleph lenses
these lenses deliver the ultra focal
length capabilities of the xiaomi 15
Ultra we are incredibly excited for our
Pro users our casual users and for every
user to limit test the Imaging
capabilities that we are going to be
offering on Ultra videography we are
introducing 4K 120 FPS recording to our
100 mm telephoto as well you can now
record in 10 bit log on all four cameras
of xiaomi 15 Ultra xiaomi 15 Ultra is
the very first Android ASUS product
partner next up xiaomi 15 Ultra
photography kit Legend Edition to bring
your camera experience to the next
level our latest
generation xiaomi pad 7 Series built to
focus your flow delivers an awesome and
Flagship visual experience is a powerful
combo of chipsets and battery for
powerful performance as well xiaomi
Focus pen thanks to its high levels of
pressure sensitivity and it features
several easily accessible shortcut
buttons to help you navigate your pad
more quickly and easily we're also
introducing a new Focus keyboard best
thing about the floating keyboard design
is its versatility it's easier to use on
different surfaces with much better
stability and balance as well as viewing
angles and ergonomics xiaomi pad 7
series's upgraded software experience
with xiaomi Hyper os2 for pad helping
supercharge your
productivity sh me buzz by Pro and you
can truly hear the difference it's a
perfect blend of premium sound and smart
features with co-axial triple drivers
qualcom aptx losses audio personalized
built-in dimensional audio and so much
more Shi Buzz 5 Pro Wi-Fi Edition with
the same Elite sound experience and
lossless audio transmitted over Wi-Fi
let's take a look at the next Pinnacle
of onr style with Shi Smart Hub you can
manage your Shi devices like your phone
pad and other aiot devices right from
your wrist we've also Incorporated
gesture controls for more convenience
with interchangeable bezels Shi Smart
Hub smart gesture control and up to 15
days of battery life s me electric
scooter 5 Max with an amazing suspension
system Elite Performance smart safety
and so much
more I want to thank everybody for being
so patient with so much information
we've had seven amazing products today
all designed with the human and the home
experiences in mind
[Music]